nein also mein thema am schluss im
zeichen der völkerverständigung wir
brauchen die zu einem versöhnlichen
abschluss in dieser sendung und ich bin
gegen diese boykottaufrufe mit china
die leute die jetzt den boykott fordern
der olympischen spiele in china
meine damen und herren gehabt den sinn
und den geist von olympia nicht
verstanden was ist olympia seit
tausenden von jahren
olympia ist wenn auf dieser erde auf
diese chronisch verfeindeten ehrte die
länder die teilnehmer das kriegsbeil für
ein paar tage begraben die konflikte
vergessen die politik draußen lassen las
den sport sport sei denn der sport ist
eine hoffnung in der gegenwart im sport
können wir uns begegnen im sport können
sich auch die vereinte im friedlichen
wettbewerb bietet finden lässt den sport
sport sein hört auf den sport und die
olympischen spiele zu politisieren hört
auch mit diesen boykott geräte wenn die
chinesen nicht bei olympia dabei haben
wollt dann dürfte sie auch keine
olympischen spiele austragen wollen aber
so geht es nicht nur noch ein letzter
punkt hier was mich auch irritiert china
baut schlimm ist auch mache ich kann das
nicht beteiligt waren noch nicht an
diesen ruhigen gebieten ich weiß das
nicht was da stimmt was nicht stimmt
aber was ich weiß war das geworden was
ich weiß ist das folgende mode der
westen hat opium kriege geführt in china
der westen hat schändlichste verbrechen
gemacht in krina man hatte ihnen zwar
auf drogen verkauft im 19 jahrhundert
der westen ist hier nicht moralisch
legitimiert sich auf ein neues pferd zu
setzen aber das ist nur eine kleine
bemerkung lasst den sport sport sein und
jetzt sind wir uns endlich einig heute
am abend in diesen unterschieden jesus
immer noch heiß ich habe ihn ja doch
sehr überrascht welche erkenntnisse
diese heitere abend bereitet
schweizer zwingen die jahner noch als
deutscher romantiker in das festspiel
und der völkerfreundschaft ja wenn es
einmal so werde wäre leider ist das
natürlich schon lange nicht mehr es ist
an sich eine hochpolitische
veranstaltung keine weiß das besser als
wird deutsch mit herrn bach der eine
sehr unrühmliche rolle bei der dauer
politisierung von allen gespielt hat man
kann glaube ich einen unschuldigen blick
auf olympia gar nicht mehr haben und
wenn wir heute also debatten führen ob
dort erwähnt boykotte stattfinden ich
finde auch nicht ob man dafür seien
dagegen aber das ist eine sehr
ernsthafte frage die ich hier nicht vom
mit mit schweizerischer kann dekker vom
pakistanischen könnte insofern finde ich
die olympischen spiele sind an sich
bereits seit 20 30 jahren vermutlich
noch länger ein hoch politikum von einer
funktion erste mal hierhin mal dorthin
geschoben ähnliches gilt ja teilweise
von der fifa also olympia ist bereits
ein politikum und musste sich gefallen
lassen dass man sich auch politische
gedanken aber sind sie jetzt für diesen
diplomatischen boykott oder sind sie
dagegen tag und ich jetzt nicht folgen
ich bin dafür diese frage nicht sofort
auszuschließen und das wirklich noch mal
gedanken zu machen ob es vielleicht ein
gutes signal sein konnte vielleicht muss
man einmal erklären was den
diplomatischen boykott wir schicken
trotzdem sportlerin sondern
unser staatsrepräsentanten fahren da
nicht hin und setzen sie halt nicht auf
die tribüne ich gebe ihnen an einem
punkt recht wird sich auch überraschen
klar dass man vielleicht gar nicht
versuchen dort reden musste ist ist die
verlogene veranstaltung ist auf diesem
erdball gibt ist olympia es ist ein
pures geschäft es hat nichts mehr damit
zu tun dass sich die jugend der welt
dort trifft und friedlich spiele
miteinander zu oder sich im sport zu
messen das ist so verlogen nichts daran
hat irgendetwas mit den alten werten
olympia zu tun
überhaupt nahmen die armen sportler ich
bin dafür die olympischen spiele
stattfinden brennen zu lassen ich finde
dafür dass man sich abrüstet aber es
nicht meine entscheidung diese sollen
mache ich gucke da fast nicht mehr hin
ist ähnlich wie beim wie bei der
bundesliga ich gucke über inszenierung
und wo ich merke die veranstaltung
werden so gestrickt dass ich auch ja
sieben tage in den fernseher gucke da
mache ich mir mit also ich bin ich bin
keine blogs kuh die man die man kriegen
also der olympische die olympischen
spiele hätten die waren schon in der
antike ein hoch kommerzielle stegen ich
meinen der mensch ist nicht perfekt
die argumente ab jetzt kommt der
entscheidende punkt was ist das motiv
hinter diesen diplomatischen boykott und
das finde ich eben auch falsch hier geht
es darum diesen kalten krieg anzuheizen
gegen riner wir haben vorhin die
britische krone ständige wunde nahm nein
haut jetzt kommt die den tieren
nur ganz kurz
eine art der spur als fortsetzung des
politischen kriegs mit anderen mitteln
und da bin ich dagegen dass man den
sport die olympischen spiele in dieser
art und weise es ist instrument ich sehe
ich würde die olympischen spiele
benutzen ausland zum beispiel aus
deutschland um dort eine vertreterin zu
schicken vielleicht kommen ja auch
diskussionen führen man kann miteinander
sprechen das gehört dazu aber ihr seid
club in
der regel
lautet kann der dem sport besseres
passieren als dass die politik nicht hin
fährt deshalb bin ich total für den bau
dieser alle zu hause bleiben und dann
sind nur sportler dort und sind im
wettbewerb miteinander und die sponsoren
von irgendeiner amerikanischen
sonderbotschafter und die darum schweren
wenn möglich zu hause bleiben und die
deutschen auch und da brauche ich auch
nicht irgendwelche
grünen-bundestagsabgeordneten die dann
dort foren machen gegen den
menschenrechts missbraucht und so weiter
sollen zu hause bleiben gut dabei kommt
also dort weniger menschen im staat
weniger allein in dem punkt bin ich
einverstanden das stimmt also dass
weniger politikerin fahren das ist ja
auch fürs klima des piraten zu fliehen
aber weniger
flugzeugen riese aber diese aggression
die dahinter steckt also dass man hier
versucht diese olympischen spiele auch
irgendwo gegen china zu bringen und da
ich weiß auch wenn herr tichy wenn sie
jetzt auch vom studienkreis sprechen
wenn du mich ihnen nur sagen
wir haben nimmt spannungen haus aus
diesen internationalen beziehungen ich
beobachte mit wirklich große sorge
taxiert über angehalten ich habe etliche
mensch hat sich warum in den krieger
einschneidende haben ich bin ein kind
des kalten krieges aber ich bin kein
kalter krieger und ich finde es ja quasi
wie man in der kurzen sendezeit die wir
heute am amt haben bestimmte aggression
die von russland ausgeht zu verharmlosen
und von china auch die die herausgabe es
sind der reaktion und boykotte sind die
reaktionen hat also vorher eine aktion
stattgefunden und wenn man es einfach
nicht zur kenntnis nehmen will das ein
ganz erfolgs standen ausgerottet werden
soll das systematisch an der vernichtung
der uiguren gearbeitet wird wenn man
nicht zur kenntnis nehmen will dass
china eine person ist ja dass sie wie
alle ausräumen das wollen am termin okay
also zum zumindest werden sie an der
fortpflanzung gehen das ist und
zumindest werden sie dann nehme ich halt
das ausrotten zurück dann nehme ich halt
dass sie bekämpfen und das interniert
werden und dass sie zum teil auch
sterilisiert werden das ergebnis davon
sterilisation wenn man das ein zwei
generationen weiter denken können was
auch und dass man das einfach so liegen
will das ist eine kommunistische
diktatur ist eine freie sehr lang und
bestellung der sendung stellen uns gerne
unterstellt was also tun haben kann ich
alles einfach nur irgendwie weg spiele
und turniere und bestellen gerät was wir
sagen nicht stehen was und ich sage noch
einmal sie sind offensichtlich ein
großes kino expert jetzt müsste man hier
einen chinesischen vertreter haben der
mit ihnen diskutiert wie diskutieren
nicht über china und die innenpolitische
lage ich diskutiere über die olympischen
spiele den schienen sich diskutieren
darüber ob der westen ein interesse
haben mit kino einen kalten krieg zu
veranstalten und deutschland ein
interesse und wenn ich ihre position
nehmen da müssen sie sagen okay aber
dann reichen olympia sechs aktionen gar
nicht dann brauchen wir massive
wirtschaftssanktionen dann sollte man
den deutschen unternehmen verbieten mit
so einem verbrecher steht überhaupt
zusammenzuarbeiten und da würde ich sie
einfach bitten und dann reden sie einmal
mit den deutschen aber zu ihren chefs
aufenthalt heute alexander kissler im
duell das schlussstatement zu china ans
olympia dafür waren die wertvollsten
redebeitrag von mir insofern hat die
qualität und nicht die quantität
ich glaube wir sehen ja generell die
weltpolitik an einem scheidepunkt man
muss möglicher anbieter als
demokratische republik und es werden
eher weniger als mehr mit der anderen
seite der macht sozusagen umgehen das
wird auch die große herausforderung
seien von frau berbalk und herrn scholz
und dem kreis zum anfang zu schließen
und vielleicht auch von herrn habeck und
es gibt eigentlich glaube ich keine
politisch unschuldigen zonen mehr und
wer das behauptet er spielt vielleicht
dann er den falschen kräften zu insofern
behalten wir die augen offen